lastly Kristen Anderson was talking to a
friend at a crowded Manhattan bar when
the man on the other side of the couch
sitting on the same couch reportedly
slid his fingers under her skirt moved
up her inner thigh and touched her
genitals Anderson shoved the hand away
got up from the couch and turned to take
a look at who was sitting next to her
and recognized the man as none other
than Donald J Trump of grab them by the
[ __ ] fame Anderson said this took place
in the early 1990s she said she was in
her early 20s and trying to make it in
New York City as a model at the time and
over the years Anderson who's now 46
years old and a photographer in Southern
California told the story to different
people she knew casually at first and
one of her friends Kelly Steadman went
to the Washington Post and told them
about it and said hey my friend
Christine Anderson told me about this a
reporter contacted Christine Anderson
she was initially not inclined to go
public ultimately decided to and she
said quote it's a sexual assault issue
and it's something that I've kept quiet
on my own and I've always kept quiet and
why should I keep quiet actually all of
the women should speak up and if you're
touched inappropriately tell someone and
speak up about it actually go to the
authorities and press some charges it is
not okay now of course as Trump has done
with all of the women who have made
these charges Trump says that she is
making the entire thing up Trump
spokeswoman hope Hicks saying mr. Trump
strongly denies this phony allegation by
someone looking to get free publicity it
is totally ridiculous it doesn't really
seem like she wants publicity the way
we've heard the story told it seems like
she feels after she was contacted by The
Washington Post because if something a
friend told them she said you know I was
assaulted and I'm going to go public
with it lots of denials from the Trump
campaign each with crazier explanations
than the last she's not attractive
enough for me to be sexually assaulting
her I never met her after actually
telling a story very very specifically
where you actually recount the incident
where you met her and of course just
this is just a flat-out denial and we
can't believe any of these women it's
interesting to me that all of these
women come out and give very similar
stories women who don't know each other
women who tell stories that are set very
very
similar to what Donald Trump himself has
said that he does right and the
immediate reaction is to just assume
that they are flat-out lying doesn't
really make sense to me
doesn't make sense to me at all and this
is having an impact on Donald Trump's
campaign polling we will talk about that
later this week before the last debate
on Wednesday Donald Trump's polling
falling off a cliff the numbers really
not looking good and these encounters
that we are now learning about
absolutely having an impact we'll take a
break back with more after this Gamefly
is sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s